yeah welcome to this game let's game
King blueberry okay let's see what
happens if he transposed to the Sicilian
okay let's try this variation yeah I
think this is how they play it nowadays
with the quick Queenie to and rock do
you one not sure if it's this exact
exact term move order oh well i don't i
don't know the theory but surprised okay
yes probably a rather dry position we're
not much is happening hmm yeah this
seems more active than 92 at least i
have fun the porn covered maybe i can
provoke him to play e 60 no I cannot hmm
yeah it's probably also good if I plane
I g5 to threaten this e6 I mean
Jack yeah the only thing I've got going
for me as the leader development if he
has got if he gets some time
everything's great for him but i have i
have the development advantage and now i
got the beef I'll others looks really
good now how does he get all of this I
got I got to be file under this big
activity no okay young perfect to f8
okay I ready to do this anyway hard to
imagine that there should be some some
better move really yeah probably bishop
f8 now I have a hard time to believe
that he could move something else well
now don't have don't have many of active
ideas the question is where do I do now
I be sure to g6 is probably well yeah
and nothing
I could simply take our cat play Bishop
to c5 Bishop c5 wat to make sure that
there's no porn break ever the c5 but it
can maybe take and play for the deep on
break there's various ways to keep in
Ned ship but i don't i'm not sure what
which one is the best this is a problem
it's a bit difficult to to tell what's
the what's the biggest possible edge you
can achieve okay let's yeah go for this
yeah this looks excellent really hard to
see how he should get out of this
now I can just um approach with the king
yeah at some stage she needs to to do
this very hot I'm to play this position
as black and are not um sacrifice a pawn
at some stage the sea porn or the apron
it's a it's difficult to do otherwise
you get get really passive and you know
you guys have now wins this pawn only
wonder if there is something better
yeah probably not him I can i can go
King d3 of course it's not it's not so
easy technique from tactical technical
point of view c5 my can take and enter
with the rook I have this extra phone
after look in front of the extra form
tapes and rook see one you can complain
yeah all this one okay I need I need to
take okay okay okay yeah I came so some
way to keep the porn he's so difficult
probably just a drone not not much they
can do I cannot give up all the pawns
are too hard to imagine what with the
pawn here yeah then i played this badly
cam it's a repetition already I cannot
do I cannot do anything here it's it's
everything avoiding the draw is very
risky simply look look I mean risky is
probably probably the can do that but
here I'm just I'm just giving this up
yeah here and he's going back and it's
not clear where my advantage lies I need
to improve before Jack Jack
yeah this is him moving it's probably
nothing I have no way to ever promote
the apron he's got the depot on himself
so it's it's no it's nothing it's just
the draw I need to improve somewhere
when I'm on the seventh I'm not sure how
but somewhere round about this stage
yeah thanks for watching